Let's look at the solution to
our prefetch instructions quiz.
Let's look first at this interloop and
the prefetch distance for
fetching elements of the b array.
We were told that each iteration takes
ten cycles if there are no misses.
And we want to eliminate misses.
So if we do prefetching correctly, there
will be ten cycles per iteration here.
The miss penalty and the memory
latency are 200 cycles, which means
that we should be issuing a prefetch for
a b element, and
200 cycles before we reach it,
corresponds to 20 iterations.
So we will prefetch twenty
iterations ahead of time, and
we will do it,
because if we do it this way,
the prefetch will arrive just
in time for b to get its value.
Now we need to figure out
what to prefetch here, and
whether we should be
doing the prefetching.
We should not be doing the prefetching
if, by the time we reach
the axis to the element of a,
know that this should be i plus 1, or
something larger, this eliminates
that element from the cache.
So the question is,
how much cache stuff does each
iteration of this outer loop bring in?
And the answer is, it brings 1000 eight
byte elements here, and an element of a.
So if we prefetch with a distance of 1,
what we get is that our prefetch
is done after 200 cycles.
There are 10,000 cycles here, so
it's in time to be accessing the next
iteration of the outer loop.
The question's just does this element
get kicked out before we can use it?
And the answer is no, because 8 times
this 1,000, ends up being 8,000.
The cache is 16 kilobytes.
So basically if we prefetch
here the element of the a array
that we prefetched will still be
there when we eventually get to
the next iteration of the outer
loop where we get to use it.
So, the answer is we should
prefetch with i plus 1,
and we should not be selecting this.
Note that we should not be
prefetching with i plus 20 here.
If we do that, there are 20 loops in
between when we prefetch and when we
actually use it, and each of these loops
is bringing in 8,000 bytes worth of b.
So if we prefetch that early, then
20 times 8 is larger than our cache,
and the element we prefetch will
be kicked out from the cache.
So that would be an example
of premature prefetching.